speaking of strange situations beyonce
heated lyrics you mentioned this to me
and i've gone and had a look beyonce's
new album renaissance has been met with
overwhelmingly positive reviews but the
acclaimed singer faced backlash from
activists after friday's record-breaking
release for a lyric deemed ableist on
the song heat which britney co beyonce
co-wrote with drake she sings spazzing
on that ass spaz on that ass
that's the first time i've heard the
lyric i knew it was spaz
let me give you the full lyrics here
okay well it's about it's
it's about uh [ __ ] cerebral palsy
which is an actual term right it's a
and is that now a term that we're not
allowed to use well right as similar to
the
british thing i think so but saying
someone is [ __ ]
medically so is actually not allowed
even
now
right and i would is is the term [ __ ]
cerebral palsy or however you say it is
that now
in that same boat that's just
first people would still be referred to
as um whatever [ __ ] and [ __ ]
that's like a medical diagnosis the
concern is when it becomes a pejorative
right and people start using it as a
slur i think the i don't even know that
they're allowed to medically say that
anymore
[ __ ] well they definitely are around
the [ __ ] thing because the person
that brought the term up is like
self-referred as that so okay presumably
it is at least a little bit so let me
let me give you some of the lyrics
bad bad [ __ ] make that bad [ __ ]
glitchy fine fine fine fine fine fine
fine fine liberated living like we ain't
got time yada yada ya yada yada yaya
yadda yadda yadda bom bom kaka
swazzin on that ass spazz on that ass
fan me girl fan me quick girl i need my
glass fan me off my wrist goes click
dimples on my hips stretch marks on my
tits drinking my water minding my biz
monday i'm overrated tuesday on my dick
the worst thing about that apparently is
the
spas yeah i have no idea i feel like i
just blacked out and i have no idea what
you just said
i have no idea what just happened that
was really really weird you know how you
just kind of like space out while
someone's talking that's exactly what i
just did to you i apologize but it was
like
i was just hearing noises come out of
your mouth and in in no way did they
make sense at all
and suddenly we care about the word
[ __ ] you are not you are not beyonce
one of the greatest songwriters of a
generation so oh yeah she wouldn't she
but they've gone back and they've uh
she's retroactively changing the lyrics
she's gonna change the lyrics so that it
says blast in
instead of spazzing i remember as well
they already did it by the way are they
updated already yes but there have been
some vinyls that were
pressed already
uh vinyls and cds that were pressed
already so i imagine those would
actually be the resale on those
oh you got the spaz edition of beyonce's
new album bro
oh
yeah dude i'm i'm all for i mean i i've
always thought that that word was
a bit touchy because in the uk that's a
word that's been used quite a bit as a
pejorative and i remember watching iron
man and in it tony stark do you remember
when he's got social anxiety oh he's got
anxiety and he's having anxiety attacks
and he's with a little kid i think it's
in the third one and it's snowing and
the kids saying like um what's going on
where are we going can you help what's
happening are you okay you're breathing
fast and he's trying to calm himself
down and can't goes and sits over a far
side and says see you made me spaz out
he says that tony stark says that
coming out of hollywood and that was
only maybe
within 10 years ago yeah um so i always
that stuck in my mind that bit stuck in
my mind because i always thought [ __ ]
hell that's a bit of a heavy word to
just be thrown around like that so
well look you you know where this is
going correct that in people will bring
issues about certain things that have
already been made and demand that they
change them
and what's wild is that we're doing it
to something that we thought we couldn't
change
given that so given that most people
stream music now
we can actually take songs out and put
them back oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and
that's a wild thing you can't even do
that with youtube videos right you could
do that with you'd have to re-upload the
youtube video yeah well i think they
probably re-uploaded i don't know how
how it works but it's just a very weird
thing but now this is where where the
conversation is ultimately going to go
is like the the potential for slippery
slope and obviously the so how far back
do you need to go in order to correct
context i mean are we just gonna
there's gotta be
very very problematic content that so
many rappers
so many songs have used the word spat so
many things have like said i remember
eminem's eminem's songs
50 cent songs with it in
yeah i mean it's just it it's endless so
what are we gonna do we just gonna go
through and pick apart all these things
this is you know this is the the
slippery slope i mean and then we have
the the monica lewinsky thing what
happened with that so monica lewinsky
she said while we're at it
you can change the lyrics to this song
where you mention me like sucking
bill clinton's dick or something i don't
know actually if they'd had anything i
don't know what the lyric is
i looked i looked at it earlier on so it
was uh like monica lewinsky done my
dress
so she was used it was like someone's
come on a dress yeah okay so then so
yeah but here's the thing it's like
monica lewinsky uh what are you doing
why do we care about you type of thing
that's kind of my reaction
monica lewinsky why do we care about you
at least i don't know is she big on
twitter or something she did a ted she
did a tedx talk or a ted talk a couple
of years ago that was pretty big i guess
she's just
been at the center of
america well maybe that was rude of me
because like i
personally i'm because i i have no idea
what mine it was
it was before our time i think that
whole situation and tracking the monica
lewinsky
did you see that
stranger things
went back and changed something in
season three because fans pointed out a
plot hole
that's dude this is gonna be endless
endless how many things have we seen
where they've gone back and taken
episodes out
i mean whole things whole seasons of
has been altered on hulu i can't off the
top of my head i can't think of but
there have been people who have had
scandals and then they've gone in and
taken their stuff off of streaming that
that for sure has happened for sure yeah
crystalia yeah he was uh taken out of a
movie completely and they re-shot his
scenes
um with obviously a much less funny
person but that's different to going
back and after it's been published in
his outreach retroactively so for me i
don't think that the plot hole thing is
not that big of a deal like if you've
missed something and the fans tell you
go back and fix it oh oh oh that's oh i
didn't know that's why they did this
that for stranger things yeah yeah it
was there wasn't something problematic i
mean outrage no it was
people were outraged but they were
outraged because there was a hole in the
plot and they went back and fixed that
so that's that's one type i guess
another one is during the production or
before it's released you find out
something about somebody that's
contributed to it and they get removed
that's also an element i don't have any
problem with that either but when it
comes to getting rid of stuff from many
many years ago i can absolutely see
i could absolutely see that happening
and the difference being is it better to
alter i actually don't think it is
it's definitely not better to go back
and alter something than delete it
outright i think it's better to
completely remove content from the ins
like if you have to give me which
version of hell do you want the version
where stuff gets deleted
for all of altered yeah precisely
because that's not the original vision
for the piece of work but they're both
versions of hell correct correct correct
yeah it's like that uh that guy the meme
of that guy with his hand up and he's
got to pick one of the two buttons yes
yeah he's sweating yeah yeah what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]